How are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now newsletter in
Spanish. Nevada is receiving 25
million dollars in federal funds
to vaccinate low-income communities.
This money comes from the
Department of Health and Human Services. It
will help 8 health centers.
health around the state las vegas'
will receive 6 million dollars for
four clinics and listen to this after
a transformation the former hardware
is now berger house las vegas' this
property opened its doors on thursday and
many turned out to celebrate
this hotel has  1,500 rooms and 60
thousand square feet of
gaming space restaurants and bars the
pool will open until the end of May
this opening translates to almost 2,000
jobs
and county leaders celebrated the
construction of a pedestrian bridge
near the high school o' bases  southwest
of the valley as a new security measure
in the area this bridge is not very far
Rimbaud and Cárter connects the
school with nearby neighborhoods
allowing children to
walk more calmly to the
school campus and finally we move on to
the weather forecast listen well
we will have some 20 mph winds
north of the valley
temperatures will be around  60 degrees for
today and it is expected to hear this on a
warm weekend with temperatures
reaching 80 degrees I am Cristian
Cásseres with super informative
Spanish illusion good day
[Music]